[Music]
Coney Island 1950s the beach the
boardwalk
I work here on base seven mentor
Carolina excuse me do you have Jenny's
here
I'm Jenny I'm pumped he's daughter
here's wife is he gonna be surprised I
marked I think that's what you get when
you marry a gangster I gotta have a
drink
no you've been good Jerrod this can't be
out here right now we're expecting
lightning storms
when you're married to a man who got
rich putting people's feet in cement you
probably never had to do a dish wife
don't like to go fishing anymore humph
she made like she liked it didn't get me
on the walk
I was the fish
you know she's a marked woman didn't she
move on I know where all the bodies were
buried did he kiss you why are you
getting so heated I'm gonna find his
poundin everything's coming apart you
look a little crazy to me
when it comes to love we often turn out
to be our own worst enemy
I know what it is you did don't you
think you're being a little melodramatic
[Music]
you
[Music]
you